on s'active en cuisine pour accueillir
les clients ils peuvent depuis le 2 juin
venir de nouveaux déguster leurs plans
terrasse qui peut accueillir jusqu'à 50
personnes
pendant le confinement ses six salariés
étaient en chômage partiel une perte
sèche pour le gérant j'avais des
réservations la semaine de 30 personnes
et c'est là où il y avait des acomptes
qui avait été versée
c'est des choses qu'on ne fera pas par
la suite s'est pas reportée un
anniversaire qu'on a 40 ans dhr fait pas
un an après le mois de mars
même s'il restait quinze jours c'est une
perte de de chiffre d'affaires de 58 %
au mois deux mois d'avril c'est 100%
donc c'était fermé et à partir du mois
de mai j'essaie de me réorienter de la
vente à emporter avant une fermeture
compliqué également pour cet
établissement se trouve une cave à vins
à l'intérieur du restaurant depuis
novembre plein de projets mise en place
difficile à tenir avec le confinement
le but du jeu c'est est de survivre
pendant une période qui n'étaient pas
fixés en établissement même s'il est
fermé nous douter qu'il ya des
assurances a payé il ya des loyers
impayés etc
une fois qu'on a eu le prêt
c'est une chose mais ces choses qu'on
aura payé plus tard panneaux
d'avertissement des consignes sanitaires
et gels hydro alcooliques à l'entrée de
leur terrasse couverte ces restaurateurs
se réjouissent d'être ouvert de nouveau
même si l'activité ne permet pas de
fonctionner normalement
il ya encore beaucoup de télétravail
toutes les entreprises n'ont pas
reprises donc obligatoirement on a
beaucoup moins de monde
voilà donc on doit tourner à peu près à
25 30 % de notre activité habituelle
là c'est pas compliqué là on est ouvert
nous car l'argent tous attendent
l'ouverture en totalité de leur
restaurant prévue le 22 juin